pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
I don't see nothing I don't see smoke I
don't see pipes I don't see nothing
pilot the bomba did
welcome back to the Garden of Good and
Evil this is what Eve sucked her first
dick Molina has got nothing to do with
us it's Friday afternoon [ __ ] we're
wrapping up the [ __ ] week it was a
great week podcast meaning [ __ ] like
that
my back is getting better I think I'll
be ready for jujitsu next [ __ ] week
I'll be flying through the air doing
backflips of death but for right now
it's you and me and us smoking some
[ __ ] we reefer I got I purchased this
morning it's been [ __ ] cultivate than
they eat you understand
I got some [ __ ] more Larry this
shit's out of respect for talking lamb
and I got some [ __ ] perennial
gee that looks so [ __ ] good you
understand even looking at weed me go
Jesus Christ if I could just put that in
my [ __ ] eyeballs and rub it in this
is the way to go but Joey enough is
enough the only way to [ __ ] see how
goodness is it's the burn I don't run no
reef and Museum you understand me all
these people are their house all this
but listen get the [ __ ] out of here I'm
smoking up token I don't give a [ __ ]
anymore you understand I'm 53 I won from
the grey one out of Wonderland a pity
they got time to be [ __ ] worrying
about [ __ ] I got nothin to worry about
the kid I worry about my refi way about
my [ __ ] family I worry about a lot of
things you understand but this I love
this [ __ ] Mazel Tov to you [ __ ]
look at clouds a [ __ ] love come out
of my long as you understand especially
with this [ __ ] reefer tremendous
well [ __ ] that's the kind of smoke that
shows up with Dracula shows up and [ __ ]
like that have reefer smoke
it's like pedophile smoke young saying
you ever go to church again go with that
benefice smoke next thing you know you
wake up your pants on backwards a [ __ ]
anyway just hard on I want to pick my
daughter up at school maybe the mice
love [ __ ] dinner with the family
giggling and that's it come on oh
[ __ ] day we got soccer in the morning
I want to get to at lunch and that's it
[ __ ] you know me keep it
[ __ ] simple ah man are in our week
next week I go back to carrying a
[ __ ] gun a knife a star of death and
a taste I ain't [ __ ] around
look Joey what's with the chitty-chat
spark that soldier
very nice very nice I could feel the
Arctic what the [ __ ] you feel Mountain
Joey
you just get stoned all these people huh
I felt this feeling of contradictory who
gives a [ __ ] I asked you a question I
don't want to [ __ ] blog back ever get
those people these [ __ ] moon style
Gentiles yeah so my question is to hit
you it worried you'll even understand
what the [ __ ] let's move a little Larry
well that's it couple bowls and you move
on like a [ __ ] champion you
understand some people he kale we smoked
the real [ __ ] camp this is generally
Caroline oh god sucker everybody wants
to be a [ __ ] genius everybody wants
to be a genius but nobody ain't done
dick ever get those [ __ ]
very nice nice I'm happy I got this
opportunity to burn this [ __ ] refurb
debt with you
yeah at this time next week I'm being
honest Vegas at the South Point Friday
and Saturday if you're not doing nothing
and then November [ __ ] 11 will but
either go [ __ ] around those tickets are
gonna go [ __ ] fat I even talked about
in there [ __ ] 3/5 even talking about
it so you better get on that will but
Tina day the next time at the [ __ ]
[ __ ] woods
Foxwoods [ __ ] comedy thing and that's it
that's that I don't have a lot of
scheduled [ __ ] work this I gotta
finish up a book headed to a thousand
[ __ ] things how did things to do you
don't say I can't be mucking around on
the [ __ ] Road but when I am on that
will to see you [ __ ] no drama
next week in Vegas
November 11th Robert Peter Boston
alright November 12th Foxwoods you know
me do I keep the [ __ ] simple right
don't forget about me
I love having this little operatory over
you okay was a great week we did what we
had to do now it's back to the [ __ ]
drawing board sit-ups push-ups watch
jumping jacks and your [ __ ] goals you
understand me two egg yolks and they
can't stop you
I pump you [ __ ] Sunday morning
before church I love you [ __ ]
don't forget about me without you I got
oh gods I got [ __ ] nothing alright so
stay back 10 minutes where you got
something I got to tap into a [ __ ]
rehab I love you guys see you next week
the church stay black